[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm going to talk about data for the 99%
you might ask what does that mean the
alternative title to this talk is 22
problems that Facebook has that you
don't face problems you have that
Facebook doesn't so get into what that
means in a second a little bit of
background about myself so I am on
cofounders of mode I like Ian said note
is a collaborative platform for analysts
data scientists and organizations the
original inspiration for mode came from
a lot of internal tools that got built
and I guess I'm kind of stand in the way
here got came from a lot of internal
tools that got built at companies like
this like Facebook and Eber and LinkedIn
and Airbnb and stuff like that these
companies represent what I consider like
the 1% of data companies they're
companies that are at the bleeding edge
of data problems they're solving
problems of really big complexity really
complicated scale I mean really big
scale really complicated problems that
the kinds of companies actually need to
build tools internally and technologies
internally to address the problems that
they have most companies don't actually
have these kinds of problems and those
companies which I refer to here is 99%
have a very different set of problems we
sell to these companies we see a lot of
these folks when when we're talking to
prospects and talking to our customers
and so we hear a lot about those
challenges that they have when they're
trying to get there they're sort of data
infrastructure data culture set up and
so they're not actually trying to do
things like run real time prediction
algorithms against petabytes of data
those aren't the problems that they have
they don't have the teams to build
internal tools they don't have the teams
to build technologies to solve their
problems I don't even need to do that
they have much more mundane problems and
those are the problems that I want to
talk about and you may be asking like
why why bother talking about these
problems if they're the less interesting
ones especially if they're sort of
solved problems there's a few reasons
for it one is it's useful to break out
of the bubble
the to say it in a way that nobody's
ever said it before it's useful to kind
of not be in the Silicon Valley bubble
when like a data engineering world learn
more about how data engineering happens
in middle America we've all kind of seen
what happens when San Francisco doesn't
get out of San Francisco
the other part is this is the market so
this 99% doesn't represent small tech
startups this represents fortune 500
companies as well it represents the
government it represents companies that
are massive like media companies massive
retail companies massive commerce
companies these are all things that that
if you're thinking about open sourcing
tools if you're thinking about building
technologies that you want to be widely
adopted if you're thinking about
starting a company to solve data
problems this is the market you have to
address and these are the kinds of
problems that your market will have to
be starting to solve so if if you're
working on things that you want to have
wide appeal this is the kinds of
problems and kind of ecosystem you'd
have to operate in finally a lot of the
problems that I want to talk through are
things that are a blend of cultural and
technical problems data engineering
isn't just a technical problem it's also
a cultural problem kind of building up
the the right culture around how to use
data what to do with it how to do
analytics at mature companies this still
doesn't change that even the biggest
company is the Facebook's and stuff of
the world they still have cultural
problems with how to use data and we can
learn a lot from what companies do when
there's the very beginnings of this kind
of cultural transition into taking
advantage of their data so uh to get
started I have 22 problems I want to
talk through and like 20 minutes to get
through it before getting a notice
though I broke this up into a few
different sections the first section it
reminds me of a sort of interview that I
had back when I was first interviewing
for jobs up before after college so I
was interviewing jobs I went to an
interview in DC I wasn't even for a job
at a think-tank the the first person who
interviewed me ask me a question of like
so tell me about your background like
what's your story and so I started being
like the simple simple typical way you
would answer it have just went to
college here majoring in this that sort
of thing and it cut me off and I was
like no no no I want to do like your
background like where are you from where
your parents from where were your
parents born which one I think it's
probably in a legal question asked but
that part aside that reaction is
actually the reaction I have when we
talk to a lot of our potential customers
we ask them like what are your data
problems what do you need from a data
tool and they give answers that are like
oh you want to go that far back so this
part is the No
we're your parents born section of data
problems that companies encounter first
when they run into is we aren't ready
for analytics the temptation especially
as someone trying to sell them a data
product is to say everybody's ready for
analytics everybody needs data like
analysis and needs data very small
companies this actually may not be true
for people who are just trying to get
things off the ground for people who
don't have customers yet for people who
haven't actually started serving their
market yet they probably actually don't
have a lot of data and they're trying to
move faster than then they're trying to
make decisions based on intuition they
need to move very quickly and there are
cases in which people actually shouldn't
be ready to do analytics they should be
focused on other parts of building their
business that said there's a slightly
different answer to this that is a much
more pernicious answer which is we
aren't ready to do analytics right we
hear this a lot from other folks as well
it typically happens after they read
some medium blog post or something about
this is the ideal beta stack this is all
the tools you need to really do
analytics correctly they'll say things
like we don't know what the track we
don't we don't track the right things we
don't know what our metrics are all of
these things suffer from the same
problem which is they're making
analytics for analytics and making the
perfect the enemy of the good a lot of
companies at this stage think that that
we have to build out an entire
infrastructure we have to have a perfect
plan for how to do things before we can
actually start start working on our
analysis and our data science and and in
this case this actually isn't right a
lot of the stuff that that analytics can
do can operate really well on imperfect
data some of the decisions we made very
early on it mode weren't based on
perfect numbers they weren't based on
data that we knew was perfectly clean
but they helped us understand like how
people were using our product at a very
basic level and allowed us to make
better decisions early on there are also
things where this is this sort of
misunderstands some of the values of
analytics analytics isn't about defining
a perfect metric and then chasing that
perfect metric it's not about you
targeting something that is a fixed
location analytics changes what you need
out of analytics and what you need out
of data is constantly changing as your
business is changing and so you never
have such thing as a right metric you'll
never actually
you're out your metrics it's something
that has to evolve as your business
evolves and you should start chasing it
as soon as you can so once you answer
these questions these are kind of the
cultural things as I mentioned they're
the early stage cultural things once you
get past this stage you actually move on
to things that are real data engineering
problems and so at this point a lot of
folks that come to us will be people who
have implemented basic tools like Google
Analytics or Mixpanel or things like
that and then looking to take it further
this is the first problem they often run
into is they can't query their data they
have Google Analytics they are
constrained by what Google Analytics
lets them do they have questions that go
beyond what Google Analytics lets them
do and they're not sure where to go next
fortunately this is a very solved
problem there's a bunch of tools out
there nail that lets you do this very
easily Google Analytics in fact lets you
dump your data directly into bigquery
these other tools all allow you to pipe
data into into these basic drag-and-drop
kind of analytics tools as well as dump
the data into a database and make it
easy to query all these things you can
do in a few clicks so this is a problem
now that's that's thankfully solved by a
lot of the great companies out there as
soon as you do this though people will
start realizing there's another problem
which is they have data all over the
place it's not just they have web
tracking data they have data in a bunch
of warehouses they have data and
third-party tools like Salesforce or
Marketo or Zendesk all this data is
really important to their business and
they need to be able to clear you all
that as well this is a partially solved
problem these same tools is a whole
bunch of these tools that it will do a
really good job of pulling data out of
third-party tools into data warehouses
for you to work on so tools like segment
5 Tran stitch at leap these are all
really good tools it's saying let's just
mirror my salesforce instance into a
warehouse and I can query it immediately
that's great and this is something that
used to be a really hard problem I used
to work at a company that we tried to do
this we had an engineering team that
focused on just pulling data from a
couple of third-party sources and now
it's something you can again do with
just a few clicks one place where this
actually does get a little trickier is
if you're trying to move data between
databases it works pretty well on top of
a modern stack if you're using something
like redshift it doesn't work so well on
top of like legacy vendors so if you're
using Oracle or using something like s
ap a lot of these tools don't
actually operate particularly well on
those things so if you're looking for
places to to solve problems that people
haven't yet solved building the kind of
modern stack for sort of more legacy
vendors is something that's still still
a thing that people struggle with of
course once you see this list this gives
me it leads to another problem of which
of these tools will actually choose how
do I pick an ETL tool how do I even
maybe I don't want one of these maybe I
want to build it myself there's a lot of
things that go into that there's a lot
of variables that may help you decide
what you want to do I don't want to get
into that too much you all probably
understand that better than I do one
thing I think that's really important to
consider though is that when you're
thinking about an ETL tool and thinking
about an ETL tool that you're building
versus an ETL tool you're buying the the
important part of it is the surface area
of that tool is the data that comes out
the other side it's easy to look at one
of these tools and think which one has
the shiniest application which one has
great dashboards to help you monitor it
that's not the way you interact with
these things on a day-to-day basis you
interact with these things by querying
the data and if the data is no good then
the tool is no good regardless how kind
of sexy the application might be so once
you go to this place now your you've got
data you've got a culture that cares
about the data great what happens next
this is the part when animals start to
complain you know I've animals working
with the data and they're there you have
to deal with the actual issues of how do
you analyze this first complaint people
typically have is our queries are slow
this typically happens when people are
working on top of data that is on
production systems or in replica
databases or things like that this
happens when you first start querying
data in this case people are using like
my sequel databases or Postgres or
sometimes if you've done something crazy
three years ago you might be using
something like [ __ ] while these
databases are all good they can be slow
you hit limits pretty quickly this is a
pretty straightforward solution again
pipe your data into into an analytical
warehouse that it will take care of a
lot of that for you there's a lot of
options for that nailh a lot of
cloud-based options as well which are
very easy to manage redshift and
bigquery are the two that we see the
most often that are very popular these
days but there's a bunch of other things
as well
that you can do there's also some things
that are on this list like spark I
didn't put that up here mainly because
the logo wasn't blue um
but there's a lot of options for this
this is again something that's a very
solved problem of if you're working on
on a database an open source database
like like Postgres or my sequel you have
much faster things to quickly scale your
queries that again know if you see
another list of things it's like how do
we choose which one of these to get into
how do we invest choose which database
to invest in I certainly am NOT going to
go to the technology of these things and
which ones faster and do any sort of
benchmarking on those things that's not
my expertise by any means I think though
one thing that's really important to
think about particularly in this 99% eco
system is the way that a lot of these
folks makes this decision isn't on the
sort of technical specs of these of
these types of tools that - - a lot of
these companies all of these databases
or Ferraris that you're driving down the
highway you can't actually take them as
fast as you need to take them the way
that a lot of people make these
decisions is on the ecosystems that are
around them one of the reasons that red
shift has been really successful is
because there's this massive ecosystem
of tools around it now there's a bunch
of ETL tools there's a bunch of
analytics tools you don't get that if
you use something like snowflake which
is also a really good piece of
technology but doesn't quite have the
same support that a tool like redshift
currently has and so when folks are
thinking about buying these tools these
days this kind of ecosystem is really
what matters as much as the tech specs
do themselves so once you've got two
data warehouse you may be working in
redshift or whatever and things like
that all good that's when you'd run into
your next problem which is my queries
are slow again this is a point at which
we see a lot of companies want to
engineer a solution they want to do
something like we'll do some fancy
partitioning we'll manage our sort keys
more actively we'll do a bunch of stuff
to make our queries more efficient well
demand our analysts write better queries
for most companies when you first see
this problem again don't do that throw
money at the problem just buy a bigger
redshift database buy a bigger bigquery
instance the mode is a company that's a
few years old it's a data company we
collect a lot of data we're a tech
company and a web company so we collect
a lot of web data we spend a few
thousand dollars a month on redshift and
it scales really well for us we also
write a lot of queries because we're
again a data company
that works out to being 30 to 40
thousand dollars a year that's way less
than we would pay a data engineer to
manage this stuff and so it's it's way
like we also can do it in a click of a
button we can just say we want read more
redshift or we want our queries run
faster we go to the console and 15
minutes later we've got it done if we
want to try to engineer a solution for
this problem it's something that would
take us months to even get anything off
the ground and it's not clear that
actually even work any better that said
even when you do that the next probably
ready to is your query or slow again
even after you have some big database
you spend a bunch of money on it there
are points in which it becomes
prohibitively expensive to buy more this
is when the problem actually gets hard
there's a few options you have here one
is to do some of the stuff I described
before about actually engineering
solutions and making your queries more
efficient and things like that that can
work and it can work again kind of a
very top of this problem and companies
like Facebook probably do have to do
those sorts of things for most companies
again and most of the companies we talk
to that's a it's a tempting option but
it's like maintaining really good
documentation it's something that
doesn't actually happen that well and
basing your entire solution on we're
going to be really well documented
usually doesn't actually work out a
second option is to to look for
different database technologies there
are things that can be much faster and
scale much bigger than some of the
things that were shown before that can
work for folks it depends again on kind
of how technically competent your team
is and how much you're willing to invest
in and maintaining a little bit more of
an esoteric thing than something like
redshift which you can maintain very
easily the third solution of this and
this is this is my preferred solution is
helping build like aggregated views of
things in your database a lot of what is
done in your database is done for the
sake of analysis it's done for the sake
of analysts being able to write queries
and understand things a lot of times
those analysts don't need to query
things like raw event streams or don't
need to query terabytes of data at once
you can aggregate that up you can do it
in such a way that analysts can get the
answers they want but operating on much
smaller data set this is a problem that
helps with the scale it a solution helps
with a scaling problem as well as making
your analyst more efficient whereas
doing things like query optimization
doesn't actually make your analyst more
efficient and
all of this data is collected for the
sake of your analysts then having this
other solution that solves a couple of
problems at once to me is something that
makes a lot more sense that then though
raises a problem okay now I have to
build data pipelines these data
pipelines are expensive to maintain how
do I do that
fortunately there's another list of
tools for this so a lot of you I'm sure
are familiar with snow in with air flow
air flows air BnB is open source version
of this it allows you to build data
pipelines and things like that for
exactly this purpose Illumina is another
tool that does this AWS has recently
launched a couple of things that are
still in data to solve these same
problems these are all Python based
tools or primarily Python based tools of
AWS has a bit more flexibility there but
they're mostly things aimed at aimed at
Python developers that works pretty well
X plenty is a version of this that you
can do in drag and drop drag and drop
has pros and cons in a lot of ways here
tend to believe more of a con for the
types of things you want to do but for
some folks that works though my
ultimately the place that I have a
fairly strong opinion here is if you're
building these sorts of pipelines and
these sorts of aggregations those are
things that should be built by analysts
and what's often the consumers of them
if you're relying on engineers to build
all of these pipelines
then you're adding a lot of extra
friction to the process of getting that
done and so if analysts are building it
it's typically best especially at these
like 9 and 9% companies to do it in
something like sequel and and sequel
based tools or things that are much more
widely adopted much better known than
Python at a lot of these companies and
so there are some open source tools DBT
is an open source tool that allows you
to build these pipelines and sequel that
practice and that that kind of
methodology is something that I'm I'm
like very supportive of and takes a
really good solution for this another
question you run into once you have data
in all these places is how do you
actually choose an analytics tool this
one's really easy you go to load
analytics comm click get started and
follow the directions from there all
right so once you do this you've got
hard problems to solve now you have data
you've got tools in place you've got
analytics tools you could buy something
other than node I don't know why you
would but good all your stuff is in
place and now you have to actually solve
problems that are the needs of the
business and this is when things
actually get hard this is when you're
not just solving the sort of tech
problems that you can go out and buy
things for but you're solving much
deeper cultural problems or much deeper
data problems don't still not Facebook
problems so the the best example of this
I think is this question of how much
money do we make this sounds simple and
it sounds like something that every
company should be able to say they
should be able to go in and be like this
is exactly how much we made yesterday is
how exactly how much we made two days
before in the real world this is an
impossible question to answer if it
sounds again simple but take a basic
company that's like a b2b company you're
selling something to another business
you've got a sales force and the sales
force maintains their sales record in in
sales force that data is human entered
so there's going to be errors in it you
have to deal with things like trial
contracts that might be entered in
differently you have to deal things with
contracts of variable length you have to
deal with things like upsells and
renewals you have to deal with free
accounts for nonprofits you have to deal
with free accounts for prospective
customers you have to attest accounts
that you've created things like early
cancellations people who put in credit
cards and the credit cards expire people
who put in credit cards and the credit
cards never work refunds all this stuff
has to be managed in in various CRM
tools it has to be managed in payment
tools if you're using something like
stripe and ultimately all that has to
mirror what's going on in your bank
account this never works nobody's ever
done this in a way that I've seen
actually work it's always a really
really hard problem it's a data
engineering problem that you have data
and a bunch of systems and you have to
make them all match it's an analytics
problem and this is the kind of stuff
that that companies really struggle with
is how do you answer this question again
sounds simple I have no advice for how
to do this if anybody wants to go out
and start a company or build some open
source software
to solve this problem more power to you
similar to that you run into this
problem as well where companies will
have two tools reporting different
values of the same metrics so say you're
using Salesforce you used to do your
financial reporting and Salesforce and
then you've gone through a lot of these
steps like no we have a really great
dashboard and a really great sort of
analytical solution for how we want to
do our financial reporting now those two
things aren't going to match Salesforce
is somehow
look different than the thing that you
have in your database and the reporting
that you've done and this creates two
real problems first of all it creates a
problem where whoever it is it's
consuming that data is going to trust
what they saw on Salesforce and not
trust what you gave them they're going
to trust the thing they saw first that's
always going to be their source of truth
it's not going to be the thing that's
like Oh trust me this is the better one
they're going to want to know why it
doesn't match the first one and this is
true if marketers were looking at Google
Analytics and now they're changing to
look at your version of that data
they're going to like what Google
Analytics says this how come you can't
say what Google Analytics says if you
don't have that trust all of this other
work doesn't matter if you can't
actually convince somebody that what
you're giving them is correct then then
you have to be you're not going to be
able to actually make any decisions or
help people make any changes in your
company so this is one of the things I
think that you have to be really careful
about you have to be very aware this is
going to happen and get out ahead of it
that that when you're reporting on
things know that it's going to be
different from what other people are
seeing in other tools and be aware of
that and help people understand why
those differences are in place because
if they don't understand it they're just
going to assume that you've done
something wrong and then not ask you for
anything else in the future another
question that people run into is we need
real-time data this is again a place
where people will sometimes read medium
posts they'll see that real-time data is
great they want it this is an easy
problem masquerading as a hard problem
don't do it you don't need real-time
data unless you're making real-time
decisions the only real-time decisions
most companies really need to make or
operational decisions about like is our
site up is our site down you typically
don't need to make real-time decisions
about how our sales are doing this
quarter if you don't need to make
real-time decisions about it don't
invest all the work to build any kind of
real-time pipelines another problem
these companies have is they'll make a
decision and they won't know why
somebody will come in will have done
something six months down the road will
ask a question that we sort of remember
having asked before and have no idea why
we made a decision then that we did this
is very much a cultural problem but it's
one a problem like data engineering can
help with a lot keeping track of what
you've done keeping track of ways that
your your analysis has been done before
keeping track of the data that you've
used in the past all this stuff can be
real
valuable for helping you understand why
you made past decisions you're not going
to remember it you think you will but
you won't and so being able to being
able to go back and say this is a record
of some of the decisions we've made some
of the analysis that we've done before
can be super valuable
Airbnb again has done some stuff here to
help out they've opened sourced a tool
they call I think the knowledge
repository this kind of library of or a
methodology for recording analytical
decisions and analytical work that can
be a really great kind of solution this
again it's much more of a cultural
problem how do you want to implement
this this way of remembering what you've
done in the past to Purdue to prevent
yourself from replicating work and
invent yourself from sort of wondering
why you've done things that at one point
you had a perfect answer for this
another problem that we hear all the
time this is like a painful problem that
still is not solved and again if you
want to go build a tool to solve it
great we'll buy it is we need a list of
email addresses so marketing teams want
to send a list of email addresses to
some people that they're trying to
trying to market to it'll be a list of
email addresses it'll be things like
they need to a visitor page three times
but they haven't signed up yet and
they've been to one event and we haven't
sent an email in the last six months and
that ends up needing data from a bunch
of different places it needs data from
perhaps your support software of like we
don't want people who we've sent a
support email to but you need also data
from your production data of like have
they bought anything on the products yet
you need sales data it needs that sort
of big aggregation of data and there's
really no way to do it other than people
manually writing queries and sending
over like exports of email addresses to
the marketing team to manually upload to
some some email marketing tool
email marketing tools will do this with
individual systems of tools like Marketo
will integrate with your event tracking
so you can say people who've been to
this page but not this page but they
never do it as completely as the
marketing team will want to never do it
as completely as your company should
want and so you end up doing these sort
of manual exports it's a huge pain it's
a thing that takes a bunch of analytics
a bunch of analysts time again
particularly these companies that that
don't have the sort of fully built out
pipelines and haven't automated a lot of
this and so this is something that again
if there were easy all sort of
off-the-shelf solutions for
it'd be something would be very popular
among these kinds of companies but as
far as I know there's there's not a way
to do this great aside from like
engineering your own thing of connecting
a bunch of AP is similar to that is
another problem of people wanting to
push data into a bunch of different
places so say your support team is is
answering support tickets in Zendesk and
they want to be able to know has that
person been on a sales call recently
because that'll change the way that they
actually interact with that ticket or
your you may be a be testing stuff you
don't want to actually a be test people
in trials because you think that may be
disruptive for their trials as they're
trying out your product all this
requires you to move a bunch of data
around into a bunch of systems some of
them may be systems that you own some of
them may be third-party systems this is
a thing that again as far as I know I
haven't seen anything that solves this
very well there are two reasons for that
one is technological that you have to
move data around into a bunch of
different pipes and that's pretty hard
the other one is that these tools think
about things differently what a user is
in Salesforce is likely very different
from what a user is in your tool versus
what a user is in Zendesk versus what a
user is in stripe and so there's not
sort of any canonical mappings of all
these things and so companies spend a
lot of time just trying to figure out
how to manage these pipes and connect
things even though all the tools
themselves are already kind of pre-built
a place again if people if people have
companies or technology out there that
really helps manage this that's
something that this is a huge problem
that again I haven't seen good solutions
for next last problem is a tricky one
for a lot of folks which is people want
to explore data on their own so folks
who have built a lot of infrastructure
they'll have analysts whose job it is to
do analysis and then they'll get
questions from their marketing team
their sales team their operations team
that hey how about we just do some of
those analysis ourselves we really like
to do that and be able to self-serve
this is tricky not because the
technology doesn't exist so if you want
to go out and buy tableau and give
people a way to do this presuming that
they can understand tableau which isn't
as easy as it sounds you can solve this
you can give people a lot of access to
data and they can go go explore it the
the part of this I think that's really
tricky again is the cultural side which
is it sounds great to say everybody can
can
being analyst everybody can explore data
but I was talking to a company recently
that had done this and they had given
people data to where people were logging
into their website so the marketing team
could see like where was their tool
really popular and they had location
data and the location data was based on
IP addresses because that's typically
the weather you do it and the marketing
team found out that most of their
customers were from Kansas and so they
went out and made decisions based on
that the reason was the customers were
from Kansas is because if you have an IP
address in the United States it doesn't
match a location it puts it in the
center of the country that's in Kansas
they're not actually in Kansas that
there's no reason for them to know that
that's like understanding where that
data came from understanding that
location data is based on IP addresses
in this kind of weird way that IP
address is resolved at Kansas isn't
something that the marketing teams would
be aware of it's just something that's
like you have to be deep in the data to
get that and so that's like the job of
an analyst that's the job of a data
engineer is to help people have that
context and so you're thinking about we
want people to explore data it's great
and it sounds great in practice but
analytics isn't just about having the
technology to do it or having the skills
to be able to query data or make charts
it's about understanding what that data
means and so this is a big challenge for
a lot of companies of figuring out where
that line is of what is it we open up to
other people versus what is we require
our analysts to do so that we don't end
up spending all of our marketing money
in Kansas final problem is I want to
share data with customers this is
actually something we've started hearing
a lot more recently let's say you've got
a company or a service and you've got
customers who use that product a
question they'll often have is how much
do we use it whose are who are most
popular people who who what have we used
it for recently who's logged in who
hasn't logged in this is something where
people will be tempted to build sort of
customer facing dashboards of if folks
use slack for instance Black has this
customer facing stats page to see how
many messages you've sent these things
can be nice they can they can be great
for the products that can be nightmares
for for data engineering teams because
you have to one figure out how to build
pipelines from from your data warehouse
and your internal tools and is something
that's production-ready
and that's really hard it means now your
ETL process has been productionize it's
into something you have to like be
maintaining a lot more closely you have
to have alerts set up for a lot more
closely than you would if it's an
internal tool that can be down for a
couple hours and people will be upset
I'm not that upset doing that that way
is one solution I've been involved in
projects like that before it's not a
great thing to do I would not recommend
it it becomes a pretty big pain pretty
quickly a second solution for this is
there are tools that provide options for
that mode for instance is a tool that
does provide a solution here there are
other options that allow you to to
basically just embed things in your
product directly and that way you don't
have to maintain pipelines there's a
third option we've seen a lot more of
people doing as well that's become
popular which is taking your data and
dumping it into a data warehouse for
your customers so your customer can say
hey we want the we want to sort of
premium analytics package we'll give you
a redshift database with all of your
data and all of your logs in it and you
can do whatever you want with it if you
want to figure out how people are using
it go crazy do your own analysis this is
pretty appealing it's something that I
think a lot of companies would be
interested in it's way harder to do than
you would expect we've seen a number of
folks try to do this have projects
planned for it
folks that I would imagine would be very
capable of doing this and very
technically competent there's not people
who are doing something that it's like
beyond what their their technical scope
would be and they've struggled with it
it's just run into a lot of pitfalls
trying to do that again if it's
something where we're there were easy
solutions for this this is another place
where there's an opportunity to solve a
problem for a lot of folks is help
people manage sharing data with people
outside of their company in ways that
isn't just a dashboard but is actually
providing access to that raw data so uh
to wrap up again I think that the most
important thing for me and thinking
about this and sort of thinking about
what are the problems that these
companies face is that data engineering
isn't just a technical challenge it's
not something that is we just need a
bunch of technology and then we solve
all of our data engineering problems we
solve our analytics problems the real
challenge is its cultural it's making
people being like you making the data
useful for people making people actually
want to use the data making people
understand what it is that they're
looking at and bringing it to them in a
way that they can actually find value in
it and so data engineering should be a
mix of these things
a mix of of building technologies to
help people solve these problems as well
as helping build cultures that make
these problems things that are that are
people are actually asking to be solved
so uh that's what I've got I don't know
we don't question all right Thank You
Ben
[Applause]
we have time for some questions so this
question is kind of a tangent I'm
curious about the mode roadmap and how
maybe it addresses some of these like 22
challenges we so we primarily don't we
try not to get too involved in in like
the data engineering side of things we
primarily see ourselves is is what
happens after that a lot of in this or
the last section of things about
distributing data about building helping
people build cultures a lot of the
things about understanding why you've
made decisions in the past
that's places we very much see ourselves
being useful we don't want to there's a
lot of tools out there as you can
clearly see that do a lot of the
pipeline management we don't that's not
a not something we have any interest in
doing but we really we really want to
think about more of the cultural side of
great you have a tool nail that can help
people write queries help people build
dashboards help people build reports how
do you make that a tool it is a highly
valuable both for analysts and the rest
of the business what are some of the
problems that analysts run into when
they really get into the weeds with that
so again a lot of that is understanding
what they did in the past understanding
what things have changed since then we
don't we don't really don't really have
plans again to get into a lot of the
weeds of data engineering stuff it's a
very well served space there are a few
holes in it but I wouldn't expect us to
build up like integrate your email
mailing lists with node kind of saying
anytime soon but you never know
I think I think you mentioned that it's
not a good idea for companies to focus
on metrics I was wondering what led you
to that conclusion it's so I don't know
I would say it's not a greater focus on
metrics it's that a lot of companies
will when we when you talk to companies
in the early stage a lot of folks will
think that that analytics is metrics the
the thing they need to do is they need
to define exactly what it is that
they're measuring like what is our force
ask companies for instance what are
these sort of fast metrics that you see
people write about
we need to perfectly define those and
then we can just plug stuff in and we'll
be good to go
I see analytics as being much more about
helping you make decisions and metrics
can help you make decisions and having
sort of consistent ways of defining how
you're how you're counting things is is
very useful there but in thinking about
it is just a matter of like if we have a
dashboard with these five things we'll
be a smarter company that's not really
how how it actually happens in practice
one because those metrics like I said
will evolve there are things that as
your business changes you may want to
show different things you may have like
different ways of measuring the health
of what you're doing and - because
there's much deeper questions that go
beyond that we kind of have this phrase
that a dashboard answers one question
and ask three more and that's something
that we see a lot with our customers is
people will people will put up a
dashboard of their metrics and they
immediately have questions of like why
did it go down what happens you know
things looks great then and look
terrible here now what and and metrics
at that point don't become valuable it's
the questions you ask next that are the
places where you really find the insight
so let's again not to say you shouldn't
have some sort of core metrics to be
looking at so a lot of the solution you
presented seems to be very Horizonte
like meaning a listing like one stack
that will do marketing sales customer
data is wouldn't any more value maybe in
having more like vertical solution that
like one that's focused on sales one
marketing or is that do you see a
difference between those two ah you so
we tend not
see folks do that partly because a lot
of the tools that get built tend to get
built and this horizontal way of like in
these ETL tools they the way that a lot
of folks build it isn't we want to
integrate with all of the marketing
tools and that's it it's this is
entirely speculation I don't actually
know where these people with these
companies roadmaps come from but it's
something where I imagine if they're a
lot of their customers not approach to
is we want to have one tool for this we
know we're going to be pulling data from
a marketing tool from a sales tool from
a finance tool we'd rather not have a
bunch of solutions to solve all that we
want like one tool to rule them all
which is a pipe dream for most cases
like that's something that usually
doesn't really exist the other thing is
there's actually a lot of similarities
between these that I think the vertical
solutions don't really it's the vertical
solutions don't actually aren't that
different that if you're working with
Marketo vs. Salesforce those two tools
actually don't differ all that much that
you would need dedicated things at the
top of it it might be different where if
you're like you have analytics tools
that sit on top of that there are
analytics tools that are very dedicated
towards sales analysis that are
structured in such a way to provide
insights and exactly like the kind of
question you might be asking of sales
but it's a sort of bottom layer the
similarities tend to be greater than the
differences so a lot of what you showed
kind of like looked at the world as it
exists today within that like 99% how
what do you guys see in terms of like
the way that like where things are
moving to like is it going to stay this
way safe five years from now we're like
we're like you know sequel should still
be the the first-class language or or
like our things are things shifting such
that if you were thinking about starting
a company to solve one of these problems
like you need to think about how the
ground might shift underneath you I my
take on that is one it'll be a lot of
consolidation in this like this this the
number of ETL tools out there that do
very similar things that's not a
sustainable set of tools
not that differentiated it's it's I
think there'll be a lot of consolidation
there probably around some of the big
players AWS will probably consume some
of these things AWS is building services
they probably won't buy folks but
they'll just like eat out from what what
those folks sell I think in terms of the
technology I mean one of the trends that
we've seen that's been interesting is
when mode first got started which was a
few years ago we saw a lot of people
wanting to do things on impalas and
hives and mongos and things like that
there has been a big push back in
towards sort of more sequel friendly
versions of that like bigquery actually
recently relaunched it recently in the
last 18 months I guess launched a way to
write more standard sequel on top a
bigquery rather than this kind of weird
bigquery ish sequel that to us was like
a pretty good indication of where the
market wants to go which is people don't
want to learn these new things sequels
very widely adopted thing and is
probably not going away anytime soon a
lot of the popular stuff again is
popular in part because of its
dependence on sequel that said I do
think that like it the the consolidation
of some of these pieces is probably what
you'll see where where bigquery itself
might be able to pull in data from other
services redshift
might like the redshift ecosystem
particularly native s might become like
this full stack where you can just push
a bunch of buttons in the AWS console
and all this stuff will suddenly start
to work but I wouldn't I mean we don't
see any sign of like the technologies
that people use the ways in foods people
want to interact with those technologies
changing the technologies probably
you're changing but the ways in which
people interact with them hasn't but who
knows that could be it could be someone
in someone's garage somewhere is making
all this irrelevant